bonjour bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7 8
weekends comme chaque fin de semaine
nous allons revenir sur l'essentiel de
l'actualité depuis lundi et bien
évidemment sur l'essentiel du jour voici
les titres de ce 30 janvier la
communauté d'agglomérations de
Saint-Quentin va passer à 12 communes au
1er janvier 2016 la nouvelle
intercommunalité qui permettra de mettre
en commun les moyens prend forme vous
entendrez les réactions des principaux
acteurs du dossier dans le cadre de la
Semaine de l'énergie l'Agence Locale de
l'énergie vient de proposer atelier
exposition c'est à Guyancourt et puis
nous reviendrons sur la mobilisation des
ATSEM à plaisir et à Guyancourt mais
aussi sur la colère des notaires face
aux projets de loi Macron retour
également sur l'annonce des coureurs
français qui participeront fin février
au mondiaux 2 cyclisme sur piste à
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
la des images pour débuter de la neige
qui est tombée à 50 ans en Yvelines en
ce vendredi matin elle n'est pas restée
très longtemps mais elle pourrait
revenir ce week-end principalement
dimanche même si la pluie sera également
de la partie Météo France évoque aussi
des chutes de grêle samedi après-midi
attention au verglas les températures
étant légèrement négatives
une autre image à présent celle du conte
Twitter du préfet des Yvelines qui fête
son premier anniversaire
1799 abonnés 1225 et 8 pour ERAR Corbin
de manjou vous pouvez y suivre son
actualité mais aussi les événements
essentiels du département et pourquoi
pas l'interpeller aussi directement de
la politique 2.0 dans le cadre de la
Semaine de l'énergie à Guyancourt
l'alecte l'Agence Locale de l'énergie et
du climat vient donc de proposer atelier
et animations pour les plus jeunes
Michael el midoro et William elle ont
suivi l'un des rendez-vous de cette
semaine
les gestes écologiques s'apprennent dès
le plus jeune âge la maison de quartier
Joseph Kosma de Guyancourt organisé une
après-midi sur les éco-gestes mercredi
dernier une politique initiée par la
commune depuis quelques années la ville
sensibilise les enfants les adultes tous
les habitants de la ville au
problématiques liées au développement
durable les enfants sont des vecteurs
très très prometteurs et plus que
qu'important dans cette transmission de
valeur et c'est pour pour cela qu'on
leur laissait les sensibiliser dans le
cadre d'animation dans les écoles centre
de loisirs ou alors comme ça le mercredi
pour expliquer les éco-gestes des
panneaux étaient installés dans la
maison de quartier stylo en main les
enfants ont ensuite répondu à un quiz
sur ce thème
on a froid au lieu d'allumer le
chauffage au maximum on peut mettre un
un gros pull comme ça on consomme on
consomme pas beaucoup
d'énergie
en plus du coup sur les gestes
écologiques les élèves ont pu réaliser
une petite maison en carton avec un
panneau solaire cette dernière peut
fonctionner entre 10 et 15 heures en
fonction de l'ensoleillement l'avantage
c'est que ça va être en fait un moment
qui va étudier que manuel et en fait ça
va permettre d'aborder un petit peu le
principe du fonctionnement d'un panneau
solaire donc là c'est la chaîne
miniature le simple fait en fait c'est
qu'il va charger et allumer une petite
diode une fois qu'il sera chargé et en
fait grandeur réelle ça va faire c'est
exactement le même fonctionnement sauf
que du coup ça leur permet de mieux
appréhender le fonctionnement du panneau
et on va pouvoir
de la coller sur notre maison alors pour
coller sur la maison je viens de
construire une maison pour une maison
avec un panneau solaire et on va voir
le panneau le panneau solaire il va
réchauffer la maison
on va voir si le soleil va nous aider à
réchauffer nos maisons les enfants ont
désormais toutes les armes en main pour
devenir les éco-citoyens de demain
comme chaque vendredi nous passons à
présent à l'essentiel de la semaine
écoulée ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'actualité locale et l'on commence avec
le groupe international de haute
technologie safran et qui a choisi de
regrouper toutes ces équipes innovations
et recherche sur un seul et même site
est situé à Châteaufort et à Meaux
également le choix n'est pas anodin il
permettra de renforcer la symbiose avec
le plateau de sa clé premier pôle
technologique en France au cœur de
l'opération d'intérêt national
Paris-Saclay et le hunterez Patrick
Jacques de dixmu donc assisté à
l'inauguration de ce tout nouveau site
c'était mardi matin
ce matin peu après 11 heures Geneviève
fiorazo fait son arrivée sur ce nouveau
site de Paris Saclay et pas des moindres
il s'agit en effet de s'affronter que le
nouveau centre de recherche et
technologies du groupe Safran en
compagnie du PDG et du Directeur du
Centre la secrétaire des tâches chargée
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche à inaugurer le site
est un exemple pour l'ensemble des
industries françaises suite au discours
place à la visite guidée du site un site
qui appartenait à un opérateur de
télécom il y a encore plus de 5 ans et
qui a ensuite été fermé pendant
plusieurs années aujourd'hui il renaît
enfin mille personnes y travaillent déjà
elle devrait être 1500 fin 2016
on fait des systèmes pour la défense et
puis on fait aussi des systèmes pour la
sécurité donc dans ce centre on va
travailler sur l'ensemble des
technologies qui servent à tous ces
métiers l'implantation du nouveau site
sur le territoire de Paris Saclay n'est
pas du au hasard mais bel et bien
choisie pour des critères stratégiques
et bien précis on a besoin d'avoir à
proximité ce qu'on appelle un cluster
d'université de centre de recherche de
collègues de l'industrie qui ont aussi
leur centre de recherche donc il y a
vraiment on va être dans le pôle
scientifique et de recherche
industrielle le plus important en France
et à un pôle de rayonnement mondial donc
c'est ça qu'on cherche ici en fait on
est persuadé l'innovation nécessite
qu'on s'ouvre sur l'extérieur une
ouverture sur l'extérieur félicitée par
la secrétaire d'État qui en profite
aussi pour rappeler l'importance de
l'innovation en matière d'emploi et de
compétitivité
safran a embauché au cours de ces quatre
dernières années 11000 salariés dont
5000 en France ça montre que
l'innovation c'est bien le levier
essentiel pour faire croître les
entreprises et rendre plus compétitives
en France mais immédiatement à l'export
et crée des emplois l'investissement
global pour ce nouveau site représente
près de 60 millions d'euros et s'élèvera
à plus de 80 millions d'euros d'ici 2018
la comité la commission pardon régionale
de coopération intercommunale la CRC
vient d'adopter la proposition des élus
locaux de fonder un grand 50 ans à 12
communes dès le 1er janvier 2016
souhaité par le préfet de région la
super intercommunalité à 800 000
habitants 57 communes à cheval sur deux
départements les Yvelines et l'Essonne a
donc finalement été abandonnés et cette
semaine vous avez pu suivre sur TVfil
une édition du 7 8 politique dédié
uniquement à ce changement majeur une
édition à revoir en intégralité sur
notre site Internet et dont je vous
propose quelques extraits dès à présent
vous allez voir que cette nouvelle union
ne fait pas que des heureux et que les
attentes sont nombreuses
non ce n'est pas une aubaine mais c'est
un scandale
vous connaissez mon front Paris je n'ai
pas la langue de bois et donc je
considère que nous ramener dans la ville
nouvelle de 50 ans en Yvelines que nous
avons quitté en 84 moyennant le paiement
à la vie de nouvelle en euros
d'aujourd'hui non en France de l'époque
de plus de 150 millions de francs plus
la feuille de céder à la vue de la
verrière 25 hectares de nos bonnes terre
de Coignières et bien je trouve qu'il
est scandaleux aujourd'hui de nous
ramener je dirais en ville nouvelle déjà
d'une part c'est pas moi qui fait la loi
et c'est pas moi qui suis ministre et
moi je n'ai rien réclamé à la ville de
Coignières puisqu'à l'époque je n'étais
pas aux affaires donc les choses se sont
passées dans les années 80 nous sommes
aujourd'hui en 2015 et te devons
appliquer la loi c'est pas bon non plus
qui est voté la loi sur
l'intercommunalité en tout cas ce qu'on
peut voir quand même c'est que
contrairement à ce que dit en repailleux
moi je trouve que aujourd'hui on est à
quand même une organisation qui me
paraît beaucoup plus adaptée que les 800
000 habitants auxquels le schéma du
préféré
et donc Henri Bailly aussi il faisait
partie de ce schéma 800 000 habitants
donc aujourd'hui entre 800 000 on est à
230000 je pense que c'était déjà bien et
on est sur un vrai bassin de vie alors
après la position d'Henri que je connais
depuis longtemps et que j'apprécie aussi
depuis longtemps je le laisse
responsable puisque il est maire il est
élu donc s'il veut aller en Conseil
d'État à lire en Conseil d'État moi je
suis là aussi pour appliquer la loi moi
je dis que la loi c'est la loi nous
devons nous réunir en intercommunalité
c'est vrai que le choix de
Saint-Quentin pour nous Villepreux
Villepreux est une ville qui est à la
croisée des
territoires nous avons des liens avec
Versailles Grand Parc nous avons des
liens avec Saint-Germain-en-Laye ou
salon de la protège nous avons des liens
évidemment avec plaisir et les clés sous
bois nous aurions certainement aimé
rester seul nous nous pouvons pas nous
avons tout fait et je crois que nous
avons supporté la contestation parce que
le projet de habitants étaient une
absurdité et nous avons montré que quand
les élus se réunissent ensemble on peut
réellement contrer ce que l'État
souhaite nous imposer et c'est une
victoire je pense maintenant l'avenir
est devant nous nous devons tous
travailler non pas à une absorption
parce que le risque est aussi là c'est
que nous voyons l'arrivée de la
casquille avec sa force nous sommes une
intercommunalité qui n'a que quelques
mois et nous voulons justement qu'il y
ait une fusion et que tout cela pour
l'intérêt de l'ensemble des personnes
qui habitent et l'ensemble des villes
bien évidemment je suis très contente de
rejoindre cette intercommunalité le
conseil municipal avait délibéré en juin
2011 dans ce sens on est en 2015 donc
c'est le début d'une nouvelle aventure
et comme Stéphane Herbault comme mes
collègues on attend maintenant avec
impatience parce que le calendrier
pouvait quand même très contraint et
d'après les informations dispose il
semblerait que il ne soit pas
d'actualité de le au moins pour les
compétences obligatoires de de différer
ce calendrier et donc de se mettre
autour de la table pour voir qu'ensemble
comment on va pouvoir porter des projets
communs et comment on va pouvoir
travailler ensemble et comme vous l'avez
dit parce que les citoyens ont été très
peu associés à cette affaire d'autant
plus que nous c'était une
intercommunalité provisoire donc c'est
très difficile à expliquer aux gens
comment quelque chose pour un homme et
que dans un an on recommence à faire
autre chose etc il va falloir aussi que
le citoyen soit associé à toute à toute
cette à toutes ces démarches aujourd'hui
ce qui est important je crois c'est
comme disait mes collègues c'est
l'identité aussi des collectivités
aujourd'hui on a en face de nous des
citoyens qui s'interroge qui commence à
se poser des questions réelles puisqu'on
communique malgré tout même si c'est à
minima et il est important de leur
donner des réponses des réponses aussi
sur toutes les interrogations qui
peuvent se poser tant au niveau de la
fiscalité que des compétences parce que
c'est pas uniquement les habitants c'est
aussi les agents des villes qui se
demandent à quelle sauce ils vont être
mangés est-ce qu'effectivement ils vont
être intégrés dans une grande
intercommunalité qu'on va être obligé de
virer pas mal de monde pour être un peu
trivial donc tout ça il faut que nous on
en soit compétent et j'aime beaucoup
Michel quand il dit qu'effectivement il
est maire donc c'est très bien tout tout
cela et nous on a aussi cette
responsabilité là aujourd'hui de de
savoir tout mettre à plat de façon à ce
que on puisse protéger à la fois même si
on a une double casquette mais protéger
à la fois notre collectivité dans tous
les sens du terme et rejoindre je dirais
la question et cette grande
intercommunalité peut-être que le nom va
changer parce que comme on va arriver ce
serait sympa de la dynamisme pour la
ville de Maurepas elle s'est construite
avec la ville nouvelle on en est sorti
évidemment dans les années 80 je m'en
suis pas responsable parce que à
l'époque j'étais presque né voilà je
suis dans 82 donc voilà j'irai aussi
d'une situation mais je vois que
finalement le bassin de vie de Maurepas
est avec la vie nouvelle elle a toujours
été nous avons essayé de construire
quelque chose avec la communauté de
communes des étangs voilà on s'aperçoit
que finalement on était dans une zone
transitoire puisque c'était en tout cas
la volonté du préfet et je pense que ça
a été finalement une erreur parce qu'on
se retrouve finalement dans le schéma
qui devait côté il y a déjà quelques
années politique toujours avec les
élections départementales à présent le
Parti socialiste entend faire une
campagne longue afin de sensibiliser les
électeurs à l'importance du scrutin
scrutin qui se déroulera donc en mars
qui me passionne pas en général les
électeurs la responsable dans le
département du Parti socialiste à
annoncé en tout cas sa candidature pour
le binôme qu'elle formera aux côtés de
François de Lignier sur le canton de
Montigny Guyancourt écouter un extrait
de son interview c'était mardi soir sur
notre antenne tout ça c'est le même
territoire c'est le territoire de
Saint-Quentin et les limites va vous
demander aux gens quels sont les limites
de leur canton à mon avis ils en ont
aucune idée c'est pas vraiment ce qui
est important on élit une assemblée de
départementale c'est ça qu'il faut avoir
en tête donc pour moi c'est naturel
d'aller là où on me demande d'aller
aussi c'était une demande de François
dauigné et en tant que responsable
politique et comme responsable politique
départementale ça me paraissait logique
de mouiller la chemise et puis de
l'accompagner dans cette dans cette
nouvelle bataille politiquement il y a
un enjeu puisque on parle de la
candidature en tout cas pour l'instant
c'est qu'une rumeur mais la candidature
qui devrait être annoncée de Michel
logier le président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines et
qui est également maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui pourrait se
présenter un enjeu particulier on se
présente pas contre des gens on se
présente pour défendre un programme donc
je sais pas qui sera candidat si c'est
lui ou quelqu'un d'autre peu importe ce
qu'il faut c'est que on puisse être
audible pour les électeurs et qui puisse
comprendre qu'on va porter leur message
dans une assemblée départementale qui
malheureusement est quand même très très
majoritairement à droite donc c'est
important
de l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
suite aux élections aux dernières
élections municipales c'est pas sur ce
mode là que non l'idée c'est pour le
coup par rapport jusque vous disiez par
rapport à Pierre bélier qui veut faire
entre guillemets le Grand Chelem n'a
aucun sens pour moi c'est un moment
donné on est dans une république on a
besoin d'une opposition d'une majorité
on peut pas avoir un problème un
programme politique dont l'objectif est
l'éradication de l'opposition enfin
c'est quand on est démocrate ça n'a pas
de sens donc on espère vraiment en tout
cas sur le territoire de Saint-Quentin
garder le quand on de Trappes avec
l'animal qui est sortante et le canton
de François Dol inier sur lequel je me
présente et toujours en politique
l'hebdo-politique proposée par nos
confrères de radio sensation chaque
week-end ce dimanche Nicolas quirinovitz
se recevra dès 18h de jeunes militants
pour évoquer les élections
départementales et pour le responsable
des jeunes udi le rapprochement de la
Gauche anticapitaliste sans le PS qui
n'a pas beaucoup d'avenir écoutez cet
extrait
de quel œil voyez-vous le rapprochement
entamé en France entre le fond de gauche
et les Verts et puis éventuellement une
partie de l'aile gauche du Parti
socialiste et du concret ça selon vous
c'est du sérieux c'est l'opportunisme
c'est du concret sur une certaine France
du programme politique c'est pas nouveau
ça fait quand même quelques années
maintenant qu'on le dit qu'on le dépeint
que la polarisation de la vie politique
change évolue c'est plus simplement
entre la gauche et la droite l'extrême
droite et l'extrême gauche c'est
effectivement sur ceux qui sont plutôt
libéraux européens et puis peut-être
plus que les autres plus conservateurs
plus conservateurs sur les questions de
société mais aussi d'économie donc moins
voilà plus souvent plus souverainiste
aussi les coupaji se fait là et
nécessairement sur les questions
d'économie effectivement il y a un
reprochement qui se fait assez
naturellement entre le Front de gauche
et sans parler forcément du FN même du
point ignore avec des boules à
République ou debout la France je sais
plus la République
donc là où il y a un reprochement qui se
fait au niveau du programme c'est aussi
une question d'homme très sincèrement on
va voir je suis pas sûr que ça aboutisse
au même résultat en France autre invité
de cette émission à découvrir dimension
radio sensation le secrétaire
départemental du Parti de Gauche 78
responsable jeune et lui il n'a pas
manqué de souligner la victoire de
l'extrême gauche en Grèce écoutez ce
second extrait
c'est une très bonne nouvelle que nos
amis de siriza qui font partie avec nous
du Parti de la Gauche Européenne et
remporté cette victoire ils ont
quasiment la majorité absolue c'est un
symbole fort
du peuple qui en a marre d'être au
service de d'un système économique
c'est-à-dire que pendant longtemps nous
a dit il faut faire des efforts il faut
faire des efforts c'est toujours les
mêmes qui font les efforts pour sauver
un système qui finalement met
aujourd'hui la moitié des jeunes grecs
au chômage qui épargne toujours les
mêmes puisque les armateurs ne payent
pas d'impôts en Grèce donc c'est un
système aberrant qui fait souffrir les
mêmes et ils ont enfin décidé de se
prononcer les leaders les leaders de la
gauche française de la gauche radicale
française espère à l'image de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon la même chose en France est-ce
que vous y croyez vous aussi la même
chose en France le contexte est toujours
différent on le souhaite on souhaite que
ça traverse toute l'Europe la dynamique
alors en France on n'a pas connu la
dictature des généraux qu'elle a connu
la Grèce donc on n'a pas la même le même
rapport à l'extrême droite même si
l'extrême droite est forte en Grèce on
en revient l'actualité de la semaine
développée sur tvfils et cette
mobilisation des Atsems les agents qui
interviennent dans les écoles auprès des
enfants à l'appel de la CFDT ce de
Guyancourt notamment était appelé à
faire grève lundi matin des agents qui
souhaitaient récupérer leurs cinq jours
de congés supprimés à la rentrée Mélanie
pocket Patrick Jacques de Dixmude pour
les explications
elle travaille aux côtés des enfants ces
femmes là ne sont pas professeurs mais
ATSEM agent territoriaux spécialisé des
écoles maternelles depuis ce matin elles
sont en grève pour récupérer des acquis
obtenus 30 ans plus tôt on nous a
octroyés donc 5 jours de congés en plus
pour pénibilité de travail et là avec
l'installation du nouveau rythme
scolaire avec le mercredi donc déjà à
nous on est fatigué les enfants aussi en
nous on nous impose un jour en plus une
demi-journée en plus et on nous supprime
ces jours de congé on n'a pas été
consulté au départ donc on nous a dit ça
un petit peu
par la force des choses lors d'une
réunion et on n'avait pas tout compris
qu'elles sont là on nous supprimés c'est
acquis un manque de consultation réfuté
par la municipalité qui a proposé le 8
janvier dernier un groupe de travail
pour réfléchir aux spécificités de leur
profession le personnel à 54 jours de
congés et que par équité sur l'ensemble
du personnel on souhaitait que tout le
monde soit au même niveau donc comme il
y a une spécificité pour les Atsems on
souhaitait donc organiser cette ce
groupe de travail qui a été déjà fixé du
moins l'organisation est prévue avec
elle pour pouvoir avec l'ensemble du des
Atsems pour pouvoir
voir un petit peu discuter avec elle
sous quelle forme on pouvait essayer de
voir organiser un petit peu tout ça
selon
la commune
ou les 35 que compte la municipalité
était en grève aujourd'hui le mouvement
doit continuer toute la semaine
et puis je dis à plaisir cette fois-ci
un autre mouvement social les agents
périscolaires ont manifesté jeudi suite
l'appel lancée par l'intersyndical CGT
CFDT sudfo ils étaient une quarantaine
devant la mairie pour réclamer plus de
poste et des primes supplémentaires
en premier on pourra dire le un régime
indemnitaire qui soit qui soit vraiment
réévaluer et rehaussée parce que toutes
ces tous
et pour tous donc pour ça il faudra une
enveloppe une augmentation de
l'enveloppe du régime indemnitaire afin
de récompenser tous ces agents qui se
sont vraiment défoncés cette année
après dans le détail il y a énormément
de choses mais ça serait trop long à
vous expliquer mais avec déjà des moyens
débloqués on va faire beaucoup de choses
scolaires il y a eu également une prime
de twittera pour les animateurs
encadrant le
contrat et des indemnités col
lectives saines et animateurs quand ils
se déplacent sur la collectivité donc on
a fait une avancée financière
d'accompagnement énorme qui va bien
au-delà des 45000 euros et qui pose
aussi quand même vous le savez
aujourd'hui
les grands donc c'est ce que j'essaye
d'expliquer
désespérément représentants du personnel
et nouveau depuis décembre et ce qu'on
m'a dit c'est avant il y avait
absolument pas d'action syndicales ça
voulait dire parce qu'il est agréable et
que maintenant il voulait faire des
actions syndicales ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
j'adore laquelle il faut quand même
préciser que on a pu noter qu'il y avait
des personnes à l'intérieur qui fait
aient dire
qui fait un don par représenter sur la
ville et d'autres
part et maladie
une nouvelle manifestation devrait être
organisée mardi prochain devant la
mairie cette fois-ci avec les
instituteurs la loi Macron continue à
faire mobiliser les professions
réglementées parmi celles-ci les
notaires ils étaient dans la rue en
début de semaine et aussi et ils
évoquent un drame social probable dans
leur rang Mélanie poquet et le Diwan
255 c'est le nombre d'emplois menacés
dans les Yvelines par la loi Macron
c'est du moins ce qu'estime les notaires
la réforme sur les professions
réglementées vise notamment les tarifs
pour introduire plus de concurrence par
exemple pour une vente immobilière quand
on parle des frais de notaire qui
représentent approximativement 7% des
frais et bien il y a un peu plus de 5%
qui reviennent à l'état le notaire ayant
quant à lui partager avec l'autre
notaire à un émolument un honoraire qui
est de l'ordre d'un petit peu moins 1%
des des honoraires alors aujourd'hui le
projet de loi Macron et qui est
d'ailleurs aidé en cela par le rapport
qui a été établi par l'Autorité de la
concurrence veut remettre complètement
en cause cette rémunération de sorte que
nous n'aurons plus les moyens demain
d'exercer notre métier comme il se doit
un quart des études notariales serait
rapidement en cessation de paiement pour
appuyer leurs propos les professionnels
prennent l'exemple d'une réforme
identique appliquée aux Pays-Bas
depuis 1999 37% des emplois aurait
disparus les tarifs eux auraient
augmenté de plus de 10% dans les
transactions immobilières de 97% pour
les Testament et 60% pour les contrats
de mariage la loi Macron veut aussi
instituer la liberté d'installation et
sur ce plan certains experts y sont
favorables
sont relativement
la loi est examinée à l'Assemblée
nationale depuis le lundi 26 janvier les
notaires eux ne baissent pas les bras et
envisagent d'autres manifestations
le stock de sang dramatiquement faible
une campagne pour relancer la collecte
s'organise depuis quelques journaux
recevions ici lundi le docteur Denis
Pagès en charge du charge du pôle
Île-de-France ouest de l'Établissement
français du sang le FS s'il refuse de
parler de pénurie il évoque une
situation très préoccupante
pour être confortable nous avons besoin
de 12 à 14 jours de stock en globules
rouges nous en sommes actuellement à 9
jours c'est à dire que nous n'avons
aucune marge de sécurité alors j'insiste
nous ne sommes pas en pénurie nous
sommes en délicatesse de stock et ce
stock il faut absolument le renouveler
pourquoi parce que
depuis octobre on sait qu'on commence à
être faible là-dessus et la période
d'hiver avec la grippe les gastro les
infections diverses fait que les moins
de monde peuvent donner il y a des
contre-indications à la fois pour
protéger la santé du donneur et aussi
celle du receveur il y a les risques de
se produire si cet appel est entendu
parfois des files d'attentes un petit
peu longues et je demande aux candidat
aux dons au donneur 1 de bien lire les
contre-indications qu'on affiche à
l'entrée de la collecte pour s'épargner
inutile et pour essayer de fluidifier
mais par contre qu'ils acceptent aussi
un petit peu d'attendre et puis l'autre
contrainte aussi c'est que nous les
poches de Sainte-Foy qu'on nous a
prélevé il faut qu'on les emmène sur le
plateau technique et donc on ne peut pas
faire 10 heures de collecte de suite
voilà en tout cas soyez patient soyez
compréhensif il y a un vrai appel qui
est mené le besoin est réel mais ensuite
bien sûr il faudra vous on l'espère on
vous le souhaite faire avec le succès
voilà
et pour terminer ce journal du 30
janvier je vous propose de revenir sur
la sélection des coureurs français pour
les mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste qui
se dérouleront sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines dans quelques
semaines les spectateurs du Vélodrome
vont voir en action Thomas Bouddha
champion du monde 2014 de l'Omnium Bryan
Coquard Élise delzen pour l'endurance
dans les catégories de vitesse on
retrouve Grégory Baugé Michael d'Almeida
et Lini Montin François Pervis même si
ce dernier triple champion du monde
l'année dernière n'arrive pas dans les
meilleures conditions nous y reviendrons
bien évidemment d'ici le début de la
compétition c'est la fin de ce journal
dans un instant le 7 8 weekend pour un
point complet sur vos loisirs je vous
retrouverai lundi 18h pour un nouveau
journal toujours en direct excellent
weekend